weed is a tough one sometimes people  just have to run their course with it  and it's safer it's better than other  drugs  you know it's better than somebody doing  a bunch of heroin  cocaine or crack it's better than that  in the sense that it's  you know they're more calmer and that's  nice  but yeah sometimes you want to get them  off it sometimes you can lose a sibling  or a friend  and they get real depthed up into the  weed and they like a damn  swamp it's like talking to they so  planted out  you know all they're doing is just kind  of sitting there like a plant they kind  of become what they smoke  they sit in there and they kind of are  unique but they're really just a [ __ ]  plant  and they want water and that's it man  they just want some water because  they're so high